Buonasera.
Cominciate a farmi un po' paura, devo dire. Comunque grazie.
Allora, io come sapete in queste tre lezioni proverò a raccontare i momenti cruciali della Prima Guerra Mondiale dell'Italia.
Il festival quest'anno è dedicato alla comunità e non c'è dubbio che la Prima Guerra Mondiale è un momento in cui l'Italia ha fatto un grosso passo avanti verso l'essere una comunità nazionale coesa.
È una delle tappe, 50 anni dopo l'unificazione, che hanno spinto l'Italia verso essere più di prima una comunità.
Però, attenzione, non è una cosa necessariamente solo positiva.
La comunità non è soltanto il luogo della coesistenza, della solidarietà.
La comunità, tanto per cominciare, in storia, quasi sempre, quando è forte, coesa, non desidera niente di più che sottomettere le comunità vicine ed eventualmente annientarle.
E questo si vede molto bene nel programma con cui l'Italia è entrata in guerra e nel modo in cui ha poi gestito la vittoria.
E poi c'è anche un'altra cosa, che più la comunità è forte, coesa, sente di essere una comunità e qualcuno la vuole guidare in una certa direzione e incontra resistenza,
e allora quelli che non sono d'accordo sono dei traditori, sono dei traditori della comunità nazionale, al soldo dello straniero.
E anche questo si è visto bene nell'Italia di quel 1915, nell'Italia che proverò a raccontarvi in questa prima serata, l'Italia che entra in guerra.
Allora, come sapete, l'Italia entra nella prima guerra mondiale quando la guerra sta già durando da quasi un anno.
Quella che i nostri vecchi chiamavano la guerra 15-18 per tutto il resto del mondo è la guerra 14-18.
Noi siamo entrati in guerra il 24 maggio 1915.
Era passato molto tempo, da quel 28 giugno 1914, quando l'attentato di Sarajevo dà il via a una dinamica spaventosa
che nel giro di un mese precipita tutto il mondo nella guerra.
Un attentato è un contesto, se volete, molto familiare dal nostro punto di vista di oggi.
Quella è una guerra scatenata per via di un impressionante atto di terrorismo internazionale.
Situazione che possiamo capire benissimo.
È stato assassinato a Sarajevo, in Bosnia, l'arciduca Francesco Ferdinando, erede al trono dell'impero austriaco.
La Bosnia è stata occupata dall'Austria da pochi anni, unilateralmente, scontentando mezzo mondo.
Fra l'altro scontentando la Serbia, che è il paese confinante.
Un gruppetto di terroristi di nazionalità serba, a Sarajevo, quel giorno, ammazza a pistolettate l'arciduca Francesco Ferdinando e sua moglie Sofia.
In Austria la reazione ovviamente è particolarmente intensa.
Gli hanno ammazzato l'erede al trono.
L'imperatore Francesco Giuseppe è vecchissimo, ormai è chiaro che morirà molto presto.
Quello era l'erede, da anni si preparava a prendere il potere, adesso è morto, al suo posto c'è un giovanotto che non ha arte né parte, sarà poi l'imperatore Carlo.
È uno shock enorme. L'Austria è convinta di sapere che questi terroristi serbi hanno delle complicità in Serbia, nello Stato, nella politica, i militari, i servizi segreti serbi.
E l'Austria decide che è venuto il momento di farla finita con la Serbia che da troppo tempo ostacola l'espansione austriaca nei Balcani.
Non l'ho detto, vi racconto com'è che tutte le altre potenze sono entrate in guerra, prima di raccontarvi che l'Italia invece in quel momento è rimasta fuori.
La guerra comincia con l'Austria che manda alla Serbia un ultimatum che equivale alla guerra, perché la Serbia dovrebbe sottomettersi a un'inchiesta condotta dagli austriaci con pieni poteri sul suo territorio, nessuno Stato potrebbe accettarlo.
Quindi è sicuro che ci sarà la guerra. L'Austria scommette che siccome la Serbia evidentemente è uno Stato canaglia, per usare il nostro linguaggio di oggi, che sostiene i terroristi,
e allora nessuno avrà niente a ridire se l'Austria punisce la Serbia.
La Serbia però ha un grande fratello, la Russia dello zar Nicola. Grande potenza, slava come la Serbia, ortodossa come la Serbia,
e la Russia entra in guerra per difendere la Serbia, dichiarando guerra all'Austria.
Ma anche l'Austria ha un grande fratello, la Germania, la Germania del Kaiser Guglielmo, il secondo Reich.
Lo zar di Russia Nicola spera che tutto sommato la Germania resti fuori da questa guerra.
Innanzitutto perché lo zar Nicola e il Kaiser Guglielmo sono cugini primi, giocavano insieme da bambini,
si chiamano rispettivamente Nicchi e Willy, e lo zar Nicchi tenta disperatamente di convincere suo cugino Willy
a non entrare in guerra contro di lui. Tra il luglio e l'agosto del 1914 c'è un frenetico scambio di telegrammi
fra lo zar che si firma Nicchi e il Kaiser che si firma Willy, telegrammi in inglese naturalmente,
in cui lo zar Nicchi dice a Willy, ma tu vedi, io devo entrare in guerra contro l'Austria per difendere questo piccolo paese,
la Serbia, aggredito ingiustamente, ma tu rimani fuori, vero?
E Willy gli risponde, ma no, io sono alleato con l'Austria, guarda che se tu le dichiari guerra io sarò costretto a entrare.
Vanno avanti così per qualche giorno finché Willy dichiara guerra a Nicchi.
Ma anche la Russia ha un altro grande alleato, la Francia, che odia la Germania dai tempi della guerra del 70,
dell'Alsazia e Lorena, che ha una gran paura della Germania e che è alleata della Russia proprio in funzione antitedesca.
Quindi a questo punto anche la Francia entra in guerra.
Quattro delle sei grandi potenze europee nel giro di pochi giorni sono in guerra.
Dico le sei grandi potenze perché si era affermata questa abitudine di designare così i principali paesi europei.
E le sei grandi potenze erano, beh, la più importante di tutte, la Gran Bretagna,
che fino a poco tempo prima era il più grande paese industriale del mondo,
che ancora adesso è padrona di mezzomondo, dell'India, di colonia dappertutto, la più forte marina del mondo.
Non è più sicuro che sia la prima potenza mondiale perché ne è venuta fuori un'altra, la Germania,
che ormai come industria ha sorpassato l'Inghilterra e anche come esercito.
Queste sono le due più grandi potenze.
Poi c'è la Francia, che è una grande potenza un po' più ridotta.
Poi c'è la Russia, che nessuno sa davvero quanto sia potente,
perché è enorme ma povera, è un mistero per tutti.
Poi c'è l'Austria e Ungheria, che è più debole di sicuro, è più debole delle altre,
però è comunque una grande potenza.
E poi per abitudine si considera grande potenza anche l'Italia.
Più che altro perché noi ci teniamo moltissimo.
E allora per cortesia anche l'Italia è considerata una delle sei grandi potenze,
ma tutti sanno che è la più debole.
Allora, la più grande, la Gran Bretagna, e l'ultima, l'Italia, sono rimaste fuori per il momento.
La Gran Bretagna non ha nessuna voglia di fare questa guerra per Sarajevo.
E fa sapere ai tedeschi che loro sono anche disposti a restare fuori,
benché la Gran Bretagna sia amica della Francia,
però insomma questa guerra è una roba, sapete, in Inghilterra ogni tanto viene fuori lo spirito della Brexit, no?
È una cosa continentale, fatevela voi.
Soltanto l'Inghilterra ha una cosa da chiedere ai tedeschi.
Non dovete toccare il Belgio.
Perché il Belgio è una creazione della politica inglese e all'epoca la geografia è ancora più importante di adesso.
Non pensate dov'è il Belgio, sulla manica, di fronte all'Inghilterra,
con i suoi porti, anversa, che garantiscono agli inglesi il collegamento col continente,
qualunque cosa succeda.
Quindi gli inglesi dicono una cosa sola ai tedeschi,
noi stiamo fuori dalla vostra guerra, ma lasciate stare il Belgio.
I politici tedeschi convocano i militari e gli spiegano così e così, fantastico,
l'Inghilterra resta fuori, però dobbiamo lasciare stare il Belgio.
I generali tedeschi dicono, ah, peccato,
perché noi abbiamo un piano perfetto per conquistare la Francia.
È un piano che abbiamo studiato per 30 anni e preciso in ogni dettaglio,
in tre settimane saremo a Parigi, garantito al 100%,
però prevede di invadere il Belgio.
Perciò la Germania invade il Belgio
e quando i politici tedeschi chiedono ai generali se si può cambiare piano
al comandante in capo dell'esercito viene un infarto,
perché è già tutto pronto, tutti i treni, tutti gli orari, tutti i piani, non si può.
Perciò i tedeschi invadono il Belgio e anche l'Inghilterra entra in guerra.
Cinque delle sei grandi potenze sono in guerra.
E la sesta l'Italia decide di restare fuori.
Non che non fossimo anche noi implicati in quel gioco delle alleanze
che ha portato in guerra tutti gli altri, eh.
Anche noi eravamo compromessi da un'alleanza.
Ed eravamo alleati della Germania e dell'Austria.
Era la triplice alleanza.
Era un'alleanza da un certo punto di vista molto innaturale.
L'alleanza fra Italia e Austria
era una delle cose più straordinarie della politica di quell'epoca,
perché l'Italia aveva sempre considerato l'Austria come il suo nemico ereditario.
E generazioni di italiani avevano imparato a scuola
che l'impero austriaco era appunto l'impero degli oppressori,
degli impiccatori, dei patrioti.
Eppure noi eravamo loro alleati.
Ed era assurdo anche da parte austriaca essere alleati con noi.
Perché anche l'Austria non aveva mai mandato giù l'unificazione dell'Italia.
Specialmente i militari austriaci.
Non avevano mai digerito tutte quelle guerre,
le guerre di indipendenza dell'Ottocento,
in cui gli italiani perdevano tutte le battaglie a custoza, a lissa.
Però poi alla fine, grazie ai nostri alleati, vincevamo noi.
E l'Austria ogni volta doveva cedere un pezzo.
I militari austriaci nel 1914 non vedevano l'ora di vendicarsi dell'Italia.
Cito un episodio pochissimi anni prima.
1908.
Terremoto di Messina.
Centomila morti.
L'Italia in ginocchio.
Tutte le scarse risorse della flotta, dell'esercito impegnate nei soccorsi.
Da tutto il mondo ci mandano solidarietà, aiuti.
Arrivano navi americane, russe ad aiutare.
A Vienna, il comandante in capo dell'esercito austriaco,
Feldmaresciallo Conrad,
va dall'imperatore Francesco Giuseppe
e gli propone
dichiariamo guerra all'Italia?
Non avremo mai più un'occasione come questa.
Poi non lo fanno, ma il clima è quello.
E allora com'è che noi siamo loro alleati?
Il fatto è che anche se l'Italia e l'Austria si odiano,
però sia noi sia loro
vogliamo essere alleati della Germania.
perché la Germania è un'altra cosa.
La Germania, ecco, in Italia alla fine dell'Ottocento,
la Germania è un paese ammiratissimo.
La Germania è tutto quello che noi vogliamo diventare,
un grande paese moderno, industriale, rispettato, potente.
Noi stiamo facendo la rivoluzione industriale.
La Fiat è stata fondata nel 1899
e in quei 15 anni è andata avanti l'industria italiana,
ormai c'è, debole, ma c'è.
E in gran parte questa rivoluzione industriale nostra
l'hanno finanziata investitori tedeschi.
Ci sono industriali tedeschi che lavorano in Italia
ed è già pieno all'epoca,
quando scoppia la prima guerra mondiale,
è già pieno di italiani che lavorano in Germania.
Pieno.
Faccio un piccolo salto in avanti
verso una vicenda che racconterò domani mattina,
la battaglia di Caporetto.
A Caporetto i tedeschi catturano 300.000 prigionieri italiani
e rimangono stupefatti vedendo com'è facile,
in mezzo a tutti quegli italiani,
trovare qualcuno che parla tedesco.
Perché moltissimi di loro sono stati a lavorare in Germania,
prima della guerra.
E quando tornano dalla Germania,
questi dicono
che paese,
funziona tutto,
pagano bene,
si vive bene,
la Germania è il futuro.
Però questa cosa,
negli ultimi anni,
verso il 1914,
si è un pochino modificata.
La Germania continua a essere un paese
che noi ammiriamo moltissimo
e quindi per quello siamo entrati nella triplice alleanza.
Però negli ultimi anni
la Germania,
oltre a essere ammirata,
comincia anche a fare paura.
perché i tedeschi
sembra che non sappiano dove fermarsi.
Hanno costruito un'industria formidabile,
sono diventati la prima potenza industriale del mondo.
Hanno costruito un esercito formidabile,
il più potente esercito del mondo.
Quanto alla flotta,
c'è ancora l'Inghilterra
che ce l'ha molto più forte.
I tedeschi non smettono di costruire corazzate
e si sono esplicitamente proposti
di diventare i più forti del mondo
anche con la flotta.
E la Germania agli occhi del pubblico
è incarnata dal Kaiser Guglielmo,
il quale è un personaggio
che ha un carattere disturbato,
arrogante, insicuro,
va in giro minacciando
in occasione di qualunque crisi internazionale,
alza la voce,
le sue caricature
con l'elmo a chiodo
e i baffoni
sono conosciute dal pubblico
di tutto il mondo.
La Germania è quello
e fa paura
anche in Italia.
Per darvi un'idea
vi leggo una frase dell'epoca.
Un giornalista italiano
descrive nel 1914
l'ambasciatore tedesco a Roma.
L'ambasciatore tedesco a Roma,
signor von Flotow,
dice il nostro giornalista,
è persona semplice,
assai cortese,
di tipo fine e delicato
e direi quasi decadente,
assolutamente diverso
dal solito teutone
ora alla ribalta.
Non sembra il rappresentante
della potenza più ammirata,
anzi, paurosamente ammirata.
Capite cosa voglio dire?
Un tedesco, per bene,
mite, fine e delicato,
la reazione che provoca
in Italia
non sembra mica tedesco.
Il tedesco
che siamo abituati
a incrociare
è il teutone
con l'elmo a chiodo
che ci fa un po' paura.
Con tutto questo
quando c'è l'attentato
di Sarajevo
in Italia
come nel resto del mondo
nessuno si immagina
che cosa sta per succedere.
Il ministro degli esteri
nostro,
il marchese Antonino
di San Giuliano,
siciliano
va dal presidente
del consiglio
Salandra
pugliese
a dargli questa notizia.
A Sarajevo
hanno ammazzato
Francesco Ferdinando
e il commento
del nostro ministro
degli esteri
dando la notizia
al presidente
del consiglio
è
così ci siamo liberati
da quella scocciatura
di Villa d'Este.
Cos'è la scocciatura
di Villa d'Este?
Villa d'Este a Tivoli
capolavoro
dell'architettura
rinascimentale
era di proprietà
dell'arciduca
Francesco Ferdinando
non chiedetemi perché.
Lui la voleva vendere
allo Stato italiano
e lo Stato italiano
per decenza
non poteva tirarsi indietro
ma l'arciduca
chiedeva troppo
due milioni di lire
lo Stato italiano
non le aveva
e non le voleva dare
però non poteva
neanche dirgli di no
perché come facciamo
a non ricomprare
un capolavoro
dell'arte nazionale
risultato
quando viene ammazzato
Francesco Ferdinando
la reazione
privata
del nostro ministro
degli esteri
è
almeno ci siamo tolti
quella seccatura
di Villa d'Este.
Ben inteso
ci sono anche
altre reazioni
perché l'arciduca
non era amato
in Italia
l'arciduca
era conosciuto
come uno di quelli
del partito
della rivincita
legato a quei militari
che sognavano
di dare
prima o poi
una bella lezione
agli italiani
per cui
il pubblico italiano
lo considerava
una figura ostile
quando viene ammezzato
molti festeggiano
pare
che in un cinema
di Roma
quando arriva
la notizia
dell'attentato
di Sarajevo
sospendano
la proiezione
e il pianista
comincia a suonare
la marcia reale
cioè l'inno nazionale
nostro di allora
c'era ancora
il cinema muto
ovviamente
col pianoforte
in sala
tanto per darvi
il quadro
non dico completo
ma una pennellata
in più
quando viene ucciso
Francesco Ferdinando
non è soltanto
in Italia
che molti si dicono
beh se lo meritava
perfino in Austria
e Ungheria
c'era chi lo odiava
e trova
che è un'ottima cosa
che sia stato
tolto di mezzo
in particolare
in Ungheria
sapete come era
l'Austria-Ungheria
all'epoca
erano due stati
autonomi
quasi indipendenti
in comune
avevano soltanto
un pezzo dell'esercito
e un ministro
degli esteri
per il resto
c'era il governo
ungherese
il Parlamento
quello austriaco
l'arciduca
Francesco Ferdinando
voleva trasformare
l'impero austriaco
basato su due
nazionalità dominanti
i tedeschi
e gli ungheresi
in un sistema
a tre gambe
creando un'entità
slava
una specie di
Jugoslavia
asburgica
sottraendo potere
agli ungheresi
perciò gli ungheresi
odiavano
Francesco Ferdinando
c'è una scena
in un romanzo
che tanti di noi
hanno letto
la marcia di Radetzky
di Josef Roth
che si conclude
con la notizia
dell'attentato
di Sarajevo
che arriva
in una sperduta
guarnigione
dell'esercito austriaco
austro-ungarico
in Galizia
e lì
alla mensa
di un reggimento
di cavalleria ungherese
quando arriva
la notizia
che Francesco Ferdinando
è stato assassinato
gli ufficiali ungheresi
brindano
gridando in ungherese
il porco è morto
questo per la serie
come va davvero il mondo
poi uno legge
gli epitaffi
sui giornali
sulle lapidi
no ecco
bene
l'Austria
decide di fare precipitare
le cose
per un attimo
si chiede
non è che magari
l'Italia
visto che siamo alleati
entra in guerra
insieme a noi
in realtà
gli austriaci
sanno benissimo
che non c'è neanche
da pensarci
però
un pochino
l'idea
la accarezzano
mentre la crisi
sta esplodendo
nel luglio
l'ambasciatore
austriaco
a Roma
che è anche lui
un nobile ungherese
parlando con un giornalista
gli dice
beh
sì
noi sicuramente
finiremo per fare la guerra
alla Serbia
e magari ne verrà fuori
una guerra mondiale
ma
voi
voi venite con noi
lo so
che abbiamo litigato
tanto in passato
ma questa è proprio
l'occasione
per dimenticare
tutti i vecchi dissapori
venite con noi
vedrete
che se l'Italia
si schiera con l'Austria
è sempre l'ambasciatore
austro-ungarico
a Roma
che sta parlando
e magari i francesi
non oseranno
entrare in guerra
si prenderanno paura
a dire la verità
la frase dell'ambasciatore
è
se voi entrate in guerra
i francesi
si spaventeranno
del resto
hanno già
i pantaloni pieni
cioè
se la sono fatta addosso
per la serie
il raffinato
linguaggio diplomatico
della belle époque
no?
ecco
e poi appunto
l'ambasciatore
austro-ungarico
a Roma
prosegue dicendo
venite con noi
tanto la guerra
si vince
l'esercito tedesco
in tre settimane
sarà a Parigi
e a quel punto
festeggeremo
l'interlocutore
italiano
gli dice
beh
dimenticate
un piccolo dettaglio
l'Inghilterra
e l'ambasciatore
austriaco
risponde
e cosa può fare
l'Inghilterra
ci penseranno
gli zeppelin
i dirigibili
i tedeschi
bombardando
Londra
dal cielo
e questo
non sarà
del
Jules Verne
ve l'ho voluto leggere
per darvi un'idea
della mentalità
di quella generazione
l'Europa
è governata
da una generazione
di gente
da bambini
hanno letto
i romanzi di Verne
e lì c'erano
tutte le mirabilie
possibili
il sottomarino
il razzo sulla luna
il super cannone
tutte cose
di fantascienza
e poi
questa generazione
molte di quelle cose
le ha viste
nascere
questa è una generazione
ubriaca di tecnologia
e quindi
del senso di potere
di strapotere
che ti dà la tecnologia
abbiamo il treno
l'automobile
il camion
l'aeroplano
il sottomarino
i super cannoni
i super esplosivi
e in questa ubriacatura
entrano in guerra
uno dopo l'altro
e l'Italia
deve decidere
cosa fare
ora
io dico l'Italia
ma in realtà
sono tre uomini
che hanno deciso
cosa fare
e il primo
è il presidente
del consiglio
Antonio Salandra
che è un uomo
politico italiano
normalissimo
che non sarebbe
passato alla storia
se non si fosse
trovato lì
in quel momento
è un giurista
come molti politici italiani
professore universitario
di giurisprudenza
poi si è buttato
in politica
è stato ministro
più volte
ma è presidente
del consiglio
per la prima volta
da tre mesi
non l'ha mai fatto
quel lavoro
poi c'è il ministro
degli esteri
il marchese
di San Giuliano
è una vecchia volpe
della politica
e poi c'è il re
Vittorio Emanuele III
il re piccolino
popolare
all'epoca
cauto
sono loro tre
perché la camera
in quel momento
è in vacanza
e non è previsto
per il momento
richiamarla
e perciò
le decisioni
le prendono
il presidente
del consiglio
il ministro degli esteri
e il re
e tutti e tre
si dicono
no
anche se siamo
alleati dell'Austria
però onestamente
entrare in guerra
al loro fianco
è impossibile
l'Austria ha fatto
una follia
scatenando questa guerra
noi stiamo fuori
la frase più ripetuta
negli ambienti
politici romani
in quel momento è
se uno si butta
dalla finestra
non c'è ragione
che un suo amico
gli vada dietro
naturalmente
noi saremmo
alleati dell'Austria
ma no
anche quella
basta andare a leggere
bene il trattato
e in effetti
hanno ragione
il trattato
della triplice alleanza
è stato fatto
da politici
che sapevano benissimo
che i Balcani
sono una polveriera
perché nei Balcani
tutti vorrebbero
espandersi
e in particolare
noi e l'Austria
vorremmo allargare
la nostra influenza
nei Balcani
e quando hanno firmato
il trattato
della triplice
non sono stati
come dire
ci hanno pensato bene
e c'è una clausola
che dice
ognuno degli alleati
prima di fare
qualunque mossa
nei Balcani
deve consultare
gli altri
l'Austria
ha mandato
l'ultimatum
alla Serbia
in pratica
costringendola
alla guerra
senza consultarci
perciò noi
non siamo
in nessun modo
tenuti
a entrare in guerra
e questo
lo sanno tutti
anche i tedeschi
gli austriaci
perciò
il re Vittorio
Emanuele III
scrive
al Kaiser
Guglielmo
spiegandogli
che appunto
l'Italia
non è tenuta
a entrare in guerra
che noi
avremmo preferito
che l'Austria
non la facesse
scoppiare
questa guerra
e comunque
visto che la guerra
c'è
il re Vittorio
fa gli auguri
alla Germania
e si firma
il tuo alleato
e tuo fratello
noi conosciamo
la reazione
del Kaiser
Guglielmo
a questo messaggio
di Vittorio Emanuele III
perché l'ha annotata
di suo pugno
a margine
furfante
che faccia
tosta
dopodiché
siamo l'Italia
in linea di massima
non entriamo in guerra
ma non si sa mai
agli ambasciatori
nelle varie
capitali europee
il ministero degli esteri
manda delle istruzioni
che dice
per ora
restiamo fuori
ma se qualcuno
ci offrisse
dei compensi
ora
quella è ancora
un'epoca
in cui gli ambasciatori
contano molto
anche se hanno già
il telefono
il telegrafo
però
però c'è ancora
la tradizione
di una diplomazia
in cui un ambasciatore
che sta per anni
in una capitale
parla bene la lingua
conosce tutti
ebbene
fa politica
l'ambasciatore
conta
e infatti
il nostro ambasciatore
Pietro Burgo
immediatamente
va dal ministro
degli esteri russo
e gli dice
l'Italia potrebbe anche
entrare in guerra
con voi se volete
cosa offrite?
Invece
l'ambasciatore a Berlino
Bollati
il quale è un filo tedesco
in genere
si cerca di mandare
uno che sia amico
del paese
dove va a lavorare
l'ambasciatore a Berlino
è filo tedesco
si è molto compromesso
sull'alleanza
fra Italia e Germania
quando capisce
che noi
l'alleanza
facciamo finta
che non ci sia
e non entriamo
in guerra
il nostro ambasciatore
a Berlino
ci rimane malissimo
gli sembra
che perdiamo la faccia
perciò si precipita
a Roma
va dal suo capo
il ministro degli esteri
marchese di San Giuliano
e gli dice
che lui a Berlino
non ci torna
a queste condizioni
piuttosto mi suicido
poi il giorno dopo
cambia leggermente
versione
e fa sapere al ministro
che lui a Berlino
non ci torna
piuttosto presenta
un certificato medico
il ministro San Giuliano
gli risponde
se proprio non vuole
tornare a Berlino
era meglio
il primo sistema
quali sono i motivi
per cui
i capi del paese
hanno deciso
che noi in questa guerra
non ci possiamo entrare
ma la principale
è la debolezza
dell'Italia
sappiamo tutti
di essere una potenza
di seconda categoria
è una debolezza
economica innanzitutto
io vi cito
un solo dato
per darvi l'idea
perché non ce la immaginiamo
la debolezza dell'Italia
rispetto
alle altre grandi potenze
vi cito un dato
la produzione di acciaio
che all'epoca
era
in assoluto
come dire
la produzione più importante
quella su cui
si misurava
la potenza
di un paese
quello che serviva
per fare
i treni
ma anche
le corazzate
gli armamenti
per ogni tonnellata
d'acciaio
prodotta in Italia
nel 1914
la Germania
ne produce
l'Inghilterra
la Francia
andiamo sempre calando
perfino l'Austria
produce
3 tonnellate
di acciaio
per ogni tonnellata
che produce
l'Italia
il triplo
e il resto
è uguale
e questo produce
ovviamente
anche debolezza militare
l'esercito
non è preparato
non ha cannoni
non ha riserve di munizioni
non ha niente
perciò stiamo fuori
per forza
ma c'è anche
un'altra percezione
di questi politici
che li spinge
a dire
quasi subito
no no no
noi stiamo fuori
ed è interessante
questa percezione
e la percezione
l'impressione
che anche se la guerra
è nata
da un caso
però i tedeschi
l'aspettavano
e la volevano
questa guerra
e sono decisi
a usarla
a vincerla
sono sicuri
di vincerla
i tedeschi
la guerra
e sono decisi
a usarla
per diventare
i padroni del mondo
Salandra
presidente del consiglio
in un'intervista
a un giornalista
lo dice molto chiaramente
fin da subito
questa è una aggressione
intesa a stabilire
una schiacciante
egemonia
teutonica
sull'Europa
e nel mondo
e Salandra
dice
noi non possiamo
farci complici
di questo complotto
anche perché
le conseguenze
peggiori
sarebbero per noi
se la Germania
domina il mondo
schiaccia tutti gli altri
anche noi
vedete
interessante
due volte
nella prima metà
del novecento
un presidente
del consiglio italiano
si è trovato
nella stessa situazione
la Germania
ha scatenato
una guerra
è sicura
di vincerla
e vuole
dominare il mondo
nel 1914
Salandra dice
perciò noi
non possiamo
certo aiutarla
nel 1940
come sapete
Mussolini
farà esattamente
il ragionamento
opposto
solo che
non è facile
fermarsi lì
perché una volta
che hai deciso
che tu non entri
in guerra
perché se entrassi
dovresti entrare
con l'Austria
e con la Germania
e tu non vuoi
aiutarli a vincere
perché in realtà
non vuoi affatto
che vincano
hai paura
però allora
il passo è molto breve
a dire
ma allora
aiutiamo
quegli altri
non è che
stiamo fuori
e basta
Salandra lo dice
anche lì
entro gennaio
forse già a dicembre
dov'è?
Dicembre
a dicembre
in un'intervista
il presidente del consiglio
dice noi
dobbiamo augurarci
che gli imperi centrali
siano sconfitti
sentite qua
non deve più essere possibile
ad alcuni individui
anormali
pensa al Kaiser Guglielmo
di macchinare
un tale attentato
contro la pace
la libertà
il benessere del mondo
la Germania è già vista
e proiettata
come il colpevole
che ha scatenato
questa guerra
e Salandra dice
figuratevi se vincono
l'ambasciatore tedesco
a Roma
che già adesso
va in giro
come se fosse il padrone
del mondo
figuratevi se vincono
questa guerra
il risultato però
è che allora
dobbiamo impedirgli
di vincerla
il comandante
dell'esercito
Cadorna
il quale
ovviamente
risponde alla politica
e quindi
quando gli hanno detto
non sappiamo ancora
cosa succede
ha preparato i piani
per entrare in guerra
al fianco della Germania
c'è un piano
noi mandiamo
cinque corpi d'armata
sul Reno
per aiutare i tedeschi
a attaccare la Francia
è un piano
e sta lì nel cassetto
ma già il 18 settembre
in una lettera privata
Cadorna scrive
certo che se Germania
e Austria
saranno disfatte
sarà vantaggioso
per noi
guai se vincessero
perché allora
si vendicherebbero
e poiché
il nostro interesse
è che siano schiacciate
così
dobbiamo aiutare
gli altri
a schiacciarle
fare questi discorsi
è più facile
a settembre
di quanto non fosse
ad agosto
perché ad agosto
sembrava che i tedeschi
arrivassero davvero
a Parigi
e invece
non ci sono arrivati
la guerra
si è fermata
è diventata
la guerra di trincea
non succede più niente
sul fronte occidentale
siete presenti
il romanzo di Remark
niente di nuovo
sul fronte occidentale
ecco
sul fronte orientale
invece succede qualcosa
l'Austria
le sta prendendo
i russi
stanno sconfiggendo
gli austriaci
in modo catastrofico
sembra quasi
che stiamo per invadere
l'Ungheria
a questo punto
in Italia
una parte
dell'opinione pubblica
comincia a pensare
che è ora
di far vedere
agli austriaci
quello che pensiamo
veramente di loro
nasce
l'interventismo
sostenuto
da molti giornali
fra cui
il più influente
di tutti
il Corriere della Sera
diretto da Luigi Albertini
che è un giornalista
influentissimo
non voglio dire
uno scalfari
dell'epoca
di più
più influente
con più conoscenze
più capace appunto
di influenzare
la politica
Albertini
butta il Corriere della Sera
nella direzione
della propaganda
per l'intervento
dobbiamo entrare
in guerra
ma non con l'Austria
e la Germania
contro di loro
l'interventismo
è un fenomeno complesso
ha tante anime
oggi
oggi uno dice
ma come è possibile
che con una carneficina
come quella
in corso
ci fosse gente
che smaniava
per mandare
anche i nostri
a farsi massacrare
oggi
rischia di sembrare
incomprensibile
no?
e invece
ci sono tante ragioni
c'era un interventismo
democratico
che appunto
vedeva
l'Austria
e la Germania
come gli imperi
impiccatori
militaristi
degli stivali
e degli elmi
a chiodo
mentre le potenze occidentali
democratiche
si battono
per la libertà
la democrazia
e inoltre
noi dobbiamo pur
completare il risorgimento
liberando
dall'oppressione
Trento
Trieste
e così via
tenete conto
che i tedeschi
allo scoppio della guerra
non hanno fatto niente
per cancellare
questa cattiva impressione
anzi
in Belgio
e in Francia
fucilano civili
impiccano gente
bruciano villaggi
su una dimensione
che ricorda
quello che faranno
poi nel 1940
39-40
in Polonia
e queste notizie
vengono ovviamente
esasperate
dalla propaganda
dei loro avversari
le atrocità tedesche
in Belgio
le fucilazioni
di civili
e tutto questo
conta
l'antipatia
per la Germania
cresce
e questo è
l'interventismo
democratico
ma c'è anche
l'interventismo
futurista
degli intellettuali
e dei poeti
come Marinetti
i quali sognano
la velocità
la potenza
le armi
la tecnologia
e pensano
che la guerra
è una bella cosa
perché deve
svecchiare
questo paese
di mandolinisti
il capo
è Marinetti
Filippo Tommaso
Marinetti
sentite cosa
pensa Marinetti
noi vogliamo
glorificare la guerra
sola igiene
del mondo
il militarismo
il patriottismo
le belle idee
per cui si muore
e il disprezzo
della donna
ancora
Marinetti
la guerra
è l'unico
timone
di profondità
della nuova vita
aeroplanica
che prepariamo
la guerra
futurismo
intensificato
ucciderà
il passatismo
la guerra
è la sintesi
culminante
e perfetta
del progresso
la guerra
ringiovanirà
l'Italia
la arricchirà
di uomini
d'azione
la costringerà
a vivere
non più
del passato
delle rovide
e del dolce clima
ma delle proprie
forze nazionali
e qui
il futurismo
si salda
con l'altra corrente
dell'interventismo
quella
nazionalista
imperialista
c'è tutta una corrente
che pubblica
sui giornali
che è influenzata
dalla teoria
di Darwin
che all'epoca
era dominante
vince il più forte
sopravvive
solo il più adatto
la vita
è una lotta
continua
bisogna prevalere
bisogna vincere
ci sono articoli
sui giornali
nazionalisti
che dicono
tutte queste chiacchiere
sulla libertà
dei popoli
la lotta
all'imperialismo
sono tutte balle
è ben peraltro
che noi dobbiamo
fare questa guerra
cito
la guerra
che si combatte
oggi in Europa
non è la guerra
della democrazia
pacifista
contro l'imperialismo
militare
è guerra
di popoli
e di razze
per l'esistenza
per la ricchezza
per il dominio
e il predominio
e noi cosa vogliamo
entrando in questa guerra
noi vogliamo la guerra
per il compimento
dell'unità nazionale
va bene
queste sono le chiacchiere
dei democratici
Trento
Trieste
non diremo certo di no
ma anche
specialmente
sentite l'elenco
per la nostra padronanza
nell'Adriatico
per il nostro incremento
nel Mediterraneo
per la nostra influenza
nei Balcani
per la nostra espansione
nel Levante
per l'eredità
della Turchia
in Asia Minore
e soprattutto
perché l'Italia
partecipi oggi
alla storia
del mondo
in altre parole
se stiamo fuori
non conteremo niente
dobbiamo entrare
e essere fra quelli
che vinceranno
schiacceranno
il nemico
e si impadroniranno
del mondo
intanto però
non c'è deciso niente
e gli ambasciatori
degli imperi centrali
a Roma
sperano ancora sempre
che entriamo in guerra
con loro o no
ma a questo punto
gli basta che restiamo fuori
avendo capito
l'aria che tira
l'ambasciatore tedesco
e quello austriaco
fanno tutto quello
che possono
per convincere
il nostro governo
a restare fuori
un giornalista
chiede a Salandra
come si stanno comportando
l'ambasciatore tedesco
e quello austriaco
risponde Salandra
un contegno angelico
sono diventati
degli agnelli
pronti a dare soddisfazione
per qualunque questione
San Giuliano dice
che fare il ministro
degli esteri in Italia
non è mai stato
così piacevole
perché tutti
gli ambasciatori stranieri
vengono a corteggiare
il ministro degli esteri
ovviamente
però il ministro degli esteri
il marchese di San Giuliano
è molto malato
e il 16 ottobre 1914
muore
commemorandolo alla camera
Salandra
che ha preso
l'interim del ministero
pronuncia un discorso
in cui dice
che l'unico criterio
della politica estera italiana
deve essere
la difesa
del nostro interesse
il sacro egoismo
per l'Italia
questa frase
del sacro egoismo
viene ripresa
dai giornali
fa molto rumore
Salandra si stupisce
ma in fondo
cosa ho detto
che la nostra politica estera
fa il nostro interesse
però era raro
che si dicesse
in modo così esplicito
in quella sede
che noi siamo
egoisti
ci interessa
solo
il nostro interesse
quasi subito
Salandra
deve nominare
un ministro degli esteri
entra in scena
l'ultimo personaggio
che deciderà
l'entrata in guerra
è il barone
Sidney Sonnino
è un politico italiano
di tipo molto insolito
tanto Salandra
avvocato e professore pugliese
è un classico
politico italiano
tanto il barone Sonnino
è un tipo stranissimo
il padre
è un ebreo
toscano
che però è vissuto
facendo affari
in Egitto
la mamma
è inglese
anzi gallese
credo
e il barone Sonnino
è protestante
che per un politico italiano
è già
come dire
un cocktail insolito
Sonnino
è convinto
che in guerra
bisogna andarci
lui si è fatto
una sua idea
che il popolo
lo chiede
poi quando gli vanno a chiedere
ma il popolo tutto
Sonnino dice
ma lo so anch'io
che il grosso del popolo
in realtà
ma non sono gli ignoranti
gli analfabeti
che importano
la maggioranza
è per pacifismo
così
per la vita comoda
ma
ma se noi
crederemo
lo cito
Sonnino
ministro degli esteri
se noi crederemo
che la guerra
sia necessaria
per l'Italia
dovremo
e sapremo
decidere
al di sopra
delle opinioni
della folla
e Sonnino
è convinto
che la guerra
bisogna farla
perché ha uno strano ragionamento
Sonnino
si è convinto
che questa occasione
di riprendere
Trento e Trieste
non la possiamo perdere
che se ce la perdiamo
il paese
rimarrà sconvolto
e ci sarà la rivoluzione
e cadrà
la monarchia
non ci crede nessuno
neanche Vittorio Emanuele III
il quale dice
Sonnino
ha i paraocchi
come i cavalli
vede una cosa sola
davanti a sé
ma Sonnino
è convinto
e con questa motivazione
spinge Salandra
all'entrata in guerra
contro l'Austria
e la Germania
il movimento
interventista
impazza
nel paese
si aprono
nuovi giornali
politici
famosi
cambiano idea
all'improvviso
il più famoso
di quelli
che cambiano idea
all'improvviso
è Mussolini
naturalmente
esponente di punta
del partito socialista
che di colpo
cambia idea
viene espulso dal partito
fonda il suo giornale
il popolo d'Italia
e comincia una campagna
fuoribonda
per spingere l'Italia
in guerra
al fianco della Francia
e dell'Inghilterra
c'è un vecchio
pettegolezzo
che tutti quanti
abbiamo sentito
era pagato dai francesi
sì certo
era assolutamente
pagato dai francesi
Mussolini
se non che
la cosa
è meno insolita
di quello
che potremmo pensare
perché andando a leggere
le cronache
dell'epoca
viene fuori
che nell'Italia
del 1914-15
era perfettamente
normale
che le ambasciate
straniere
pagavano i giornalisti
e pagavano
anche i politici
e non solo
pagavano i giornalisti
ma compravano
proprio i giornali
sotto gli occhi
di tutti
in quei mesi
l'ambasciata tedesca
compra la nazione
di Firenze
e progetta
di comprare
il messaggero
poi il messaggero
non lo comprano
ma insomma
si fa alla luce
del sole
e solo pochi giornali
di estrema sinistra
o repubblicani
pubblicano articoli
in cui si dice
ma stiamo dando
uno spettacolo
indecoroso
c'è un fiume d'oro
che arriva su Roma
per comprare
i nostri giornali
i nostri giornalisti
siamo in vendita
al miglior offerente
la campagna interventista
coinvolge molto
i giovani
gli studenti
è importante
sono pochi
pochissimi
rispetto a oggi
ma sono la classe dirigente
di domani
e gli studenti
sono in massa
per l'intervento
per la guerra
risultato
succedono scene
che non ci immagineremmo
nell'Italia
del 1914
ma magari
in altri anni
sì
il 9 dicembre
del 1914
alla Sapienza
deve far lezione
il filologo
Cesare De Lollis
grande filologo
grande amico
della Germania
già da tempo
insultato sui giornali
pubblicamente
come traditore
perché amico
della Germania
quel giorno
gli studenti
gli impediscono
con la violenza
di entrare in aula
e di fare lezione
invece in aula
arriva
Filippo Tommaso Marinetti
il quale sale
in piedi
sulla cattedra
arringa la folla
incitando alla guerra
contro la Germania
urla
fischia
spacca i vetri
dell'aula
arriva il rettore
della Sapienza
siamo a Roma
alla Sapienza
non so se l'ho detto
arriva il rettore
della Sapienza
e fa a Marinetti
lei profana
questa cattedra
Marinetti risponde
me ne frego
e uno non sa
se siamo appunto
già nel 22
o se siamo già
nel 68
ma insomma
sono cose
che non ci saremmo
immaginati
nell'Italia
della bella epoca
invece nel 14
succedono
gli ambasciatori
tedesco
soprattutto austriaco
cosa fanno?
fanno promesse
o meglio
il tedesco
fa promesse
perché noi vogliamo
Trento e Trieste
quindi è l'Austria
che deve mollare
e l'Austria
non ci sente
i tedeschi
insistono
noi abbiamo poi letto
le carte segrete
da cui risulta
che il Kaiser
Guglielmo
e i suoi ministri
fanno pressioni
sugli austriaci
dicendo
promettete Trento e Trieste
agli italiani
per favore
poi tutt'al più
dopo la guerra
non gliele diamo
ma intanto
promettetele
il Vaticano interviene
il Vaticano ci tiene molto
che l'Italia resti neutrale
il Vaticano ha un rapporto
molto forte
con l'Austria
grande potenza
cattolica
un personaggio
di cui poi si parlerà ancora
Monsignor Pacelli
futuro più dodicesimo
viene spedito
dal Papa a Vienna
in carico
convince il vecchio imperatore
a cedere almeno Trento
il vecchio imperatore
non ci sente
i tedeschi
cambiano l'ambasciatore a Roma
il signor von Flotow
ve lo ricordate
quello delicato
gentile
che non sembra neanche un tedesco
non va bene
nell'occasione
mandano un pezzo da 90
il principe Bülow
che è stato già
primo ministro
ministro degli esteri
del Reich
e che è un grande
filo italiano
ha sposato una principessa
siciliana
Bülow si installa
nell'ambasciata tedesca
a Roma
comincia a spendere soldi
comprare giornalisti
e fare promesse
gli italiani
gli chiedono
ma Trento
Bülow risponde
ci sto lavorando
ma lo sapete
come sono fatti
gli austriaci
perché non potremmo
promettervi invece
e di fatto
gli promettono
arriva con la lista
delle promesse
Nizza
la Savoia
la Corsica
Tunisi
tutta roba
che non è loro
e di conseguenza
ma gli italiani
sono testardi
vogliono Trento
a un certo punto
il Kaiser
Francesco Giuseppe
si convince a metà
si scopre che il Trentino
in realtà
nel medioevo
era formato
da una contea
e un vescovado
la contea
è feudo dell'imperatore
lui non la vuole cedere
ma il vescovado
di Trento
magari sì
quando l'ambasciatore
austriaco
va a raccontare
queste cose
al nostro governo
si mettono le mani
nei capelli
questa gente
fa ancora la diplomazia
a base di feudi
e consulta araldica
niente
il governo italiano
entro gennaio
ha deciso
la guerra
l'unica cosa
è che siccome
non siamo pronti
bisogna tirare
un po' in lungo
perciò il governo
notate come funzionava
non voglio dire
la democrazia
però c'era il suffragio
universale
come funzionava
l'Italia parlamentare
di allora
il governo
convoca i giornalisti
uno per uno
e spiega
quello che si aspetta
da loro
Salandra
presidente del consiglio
al direttore
della tribuna
dice in buona sostanza
cominciate a preparare
l'opinione pubblica
ma senza esagerare
perché non siamo
ancora sicuri
per ora
è bene
che la stampa
si conduca
con prudenza
e non ecciti
né deprima
conviene
come si fa
nelle osterie
di campagna
con la pasta
e col riso
tenere
l'opinione pubblica
a mezza cottura
vuol dire
sì
forse
ma
intanto trattiamo
con gli alleati
ci siamo decisi
a Londra
si aprono i negoziati
da Roma
è arrivata
una lista di richieste
per entrare in guerra
insieme a voi
vogliamo
il Trentino
ma non solo
anche il Suttirolo
a questo punto
non solo Trento
ma anche Bolzano
fino al Brennero
Trieste
la Venezia Giulia
l'Istria
la Dalmazia
con le sue isole
Valona
in Albania
il bacino
carbonifero
di Adalia
in Turchia
uno dei principali
politici inglesi
dell'epoca
Lloyd George
nelle sue memorie
scriverà
nessuno di noi
si preoccupò
di sapere
con precisione
cosa voleva l'Italia
l'importante
vi diciamo
di sì
su tutto
dai che ne abbiamo
ancora un pezzetto
sforerò un pochino
ma di poco
promesso
il 26 aprile
viene firmato
il patto di Londra
che impegna
l'Italia
a entrare in guerra
entro un mese
ricordatevi le date
26 aprile
e noi
il 24 maggio
entreremo in guerra
l'ultimo articolo
del patto di Londra
dichiara
questo accordo
verrà mantenuto
segreto
lo sanno
soltanto
Salandra
Sonnino
e il re
il quale re
manda dei telegrammi
al re di Inghilterra
e allo zar di Russia
dicendo
congratulazioni
adesso siamo alleati
stiamo per entrare in guerra
al vostro fianco
firmato il patto di Londra
a Salandra
e Sonnino
e al re
viene in mente
un piccolo dettaglio
non è ben chiaro
se avevano il potere
di fare questa cosa
perché
l'hanno firmato
il Parlamento
non sa niente
è in vacanza
ha sospeso i lavori
a marzo
deve riaprire
il 12 maggio
e il Parlamento
vanno a vedere
lo statuto
cosa dice
Sonnino dice
ah fantastico
lo statuto dice
che il re
ha il potere
di dichiarare la guerra
siamo a posto
però lo statuto
dice anche
che poi la Camera
deve confermare
i crediti di guerra
e i pieni poteri
al governo
quindi ci vuole
la conferma
della Camera
e la Camera
in realtà
in maggioranza
è neutralista
qui devo introdurre
un nuovo personaggio
l'ultimo
spero che introduco
finora non l'abbiamo citato
per niente
ma è il convitato
di Pietra
per tutti loro
era un'ossessione
finora non è comparso
Giolitti
che era stato padrone
della politica italiana
per dieci anni
quindici anni
un personaggio
che aveva influenzato
enormemente
la politica italiana
e che nel marzo
del 14
si era dimesso
per una crisi parlamentare
minore
uno di quei casi
in cui un governo
dice ma sì
è meglio fare un po'
di alternanza
mi dimetto
per un po'
metto uno
che non conta niente
chi mettiamo
Salandra
ecco
io
Giolitti
sto fuori per un po'
e poi torno
tanto il Parlamento
lo controllo io
ed è vero
Giolitti
ha il controllo
della maggioranza
dei parlamentari
Giolitti
non voglio farvi
perdere tempo
ma è stato
un protagonista
della storia italiana
di dimensioni enormi
ha governato
per tanti anni
e ovviamente
tanti hanno cominciato
a odiarlo
gli avversari politici
e anche quelli
del suo partito
lo odia
la borghesia
di destra
perché Giolitti
ha autorizzato
gli scioperi
le camere del lavoro
ha dato il suffragio
universale
ma lo odiano
anche molti progressisti
perché Giolitti
al nord
ha fatto gli accordi
con i sindacati
ma al sud
come denuncia
Gaetano Salvemini
grande meridionalista
in un libro
che esce proprio
in quegli anni
e che si intitola
il ministro
della malavita
al sud
Giolitti
governa
con le squadracce
con i pestaggi
con la polizia
che mette in galera
gli oppositori
con cose
inimmaginabili
che anche lì
a leggere il libro
di Salvemini
c'è da mettersi
le mani nei capelli
di quello che succedeva
alle elezioni
in Italia
nei primi anni
del novecento
quindi Giolitti
è odiatissimo
e adesso
per uno sbaglio
suo non si trova
al potere
però
però adesso
Giolitti e i suoi
cominciano a subodorare
anche se il patto
di Londra
è segreto
però i preparativi
si vedono
e allora
i deputati
cominciano a agitarsi
la camera è chiusa
riaprirà il 12 maggio
i deputati
ai primi di maggio
sono già a Roma
Montecitorio
fisicamente è aperto
i deputati
vanno e vengono
il governo
il 7 maggio
per prudenza
proroga l'apertura
anziché il 12
le apriamo il 20
le camere
a questo punto
la situazione precipita
Giolitti capisce
che il governo
lo sta ingannando
perché a lui dicono
no no
non è deciso niente
ancora
Giolitti capisce
che l'hanno ingannato
a un giornalista
dice
mi spiace dirlo
questo di Salandra
è stato tutto
un inganno
da pugliese
comunque
Giolitti
si precipita a Roma
e il 9 maggio
il governo
è terrorizzato
tanto che fa
organizzare manifestazioni
spontanee
fra virgolette
contro Giolitti
alla stazione di Torino
quando parte
e alla stazione di Roma
quando arriva
anche questa
è una cosa sbalorditiva
come si faceva politica
in quell'Italia
Malagodi
grande giornalista
direttore della tribuna
scrive nel suo diario
è arrivato Giolitti
contro il quale
sono state organizzate
d'accordo
col ministero
degli interni
e la polizia
manifestazioni
alla sua partenza
da Torino
e al suo arrivo
a Roma
capite che roba
dopodiché
Giolitti
è fuori di sé
dichiarazione di Giolitti
ai giornalisti
la gente che ha il governo
meriterebbe di essere
fucilata
vogliono portare
l'Italia alla guerra
senza nessun motivo
e Giolitti
insiste
questa guerra
non la possiamo fare
l'Italia è troppo debole
uno dei suoi argomenti
è molto interessante
dice ragazzi
io ho governato
tutti questi anni
abbiamo fatto
la guerra di Libia
lo so solo io
cos'è il nostro esercito
ho dovuto sempre
falsificare
i bollettini
degli scontri
in Libia
per non mostrare
che non si vinceva
se non si era
in dieci contro uno
sempre Giolitti
a un giornalista
i generali valgono poco
sono usciti
dai ranghi
quando si mandavano
nell'esercito
i figli di famiglia
più stupidi
dei quali
non si sapeva
cosa fare
finalmente
siamo così poveri
che una guerra
non ce la possiamo permettere
Giolitti
piomba a Roma
il 9 maggio
il 10 maggio
300 deputati
e più di 100 senatori
passano da casa sua
a lasciare
il loro biglietto
da visita
che vuol dire
che sono d'accordo
con lui
e quindi
la maggioranza
della Camera
è contro
la dichiarazione
di guerra
a questo punto
panico
perché il governo
scopre che nel frattempo
ha già firmato
l'alleanza
e il re
ha già mandato
i telegrammi
ai suoi colleghi
allora
si tenta
di contenere
i danni
Salandra
dice va bene
io mi dimetto
è l'unica cosa
che posso fare
il re dice
sì
e io
io devo abdicare
qui c'è
e qui è veramente
una cosa favolosa
perché il re
Vittorio Emanuele III
in quei giorni
al suo presidente
del consiglio
e anche a Giolitti
dice le seguenti cose
primo
sì io
mi sono compromesso
ho mandato i telegrammi
ai miei colleghi
il re d'Inghilterra
lo zar
mi sono compromesso
devo abdicare
e va benissimo così
il re
lo farà mio cugino
il duca d'Aosta
a lui piace
a lui piacciono
tutte queste cerimonie
che a me mi seccano
profondamente
poi dice
il re
che lui è pronto
ad andarsene
che ha sempre pensato
che gli piacerebbe
vivere alle Baleari
o ad Antib
che non gliene
importava
proprio niente
ancora
dice il re
ai suoi ministri
io forse
non sarei venuto qui
al Quirinale
cioè al Palazzo Reale
e volevo parlarne
a mio padre
ma egli morì
in quel modo
e io fui costretto
a venire
sapete
Umberto I
assassinato a Monza
e Vittorio
15 anni dopo
Vittorio dice
o cerca di far credere
ai suoi ministri
che lui prima
avrebbe voluto
lasciar perdere
allora
il ministro
il governo
si dimette
il re
minaccia
di abdicare
il Vaticano
decide
che è il momento
per spingere
manda emissari
dai ministri
cattolici
per dirgli
che quella
è l'ultima occasione
per evitare la guerra
tanto perché
siano chiari
i termini
dei discorsi
Monsignor Boncompagni
Ludovisi
va da un ministro
e gli dice
che la guerra
bisogna evitarla
la guerra è ingiusta
la vuole solo
virgolette
quell'ebreo
traditore
di sonnino
il papa
fa sapere
al re
che basta insistere
un po'
e l'Austria
è pronta a cedere
tutto
anche Gorizia
tutto il mondo
sa che a Roma
sta succedendo
questo psicodramma
per cui
il Kaiser Guglielmo
l'imperatore
Francesco Giuseppe
i loro primi ministri
e i loro capi
di stato maggiore
si incontrano
il 9 maggio
al comando supremo
austriaco
e lì si decide
che gli austriaci
prometteranno
tutto quello
che gli italiani
vogliono
gli austriaci
fanno mettere
a verbale
però poi
dopo la guerra
ci riprendiamo
tutto
e qui
bisogna capire
cosa succede
perché è una cosa
quasi incomprensibile
è l'ultimo atto
di questo dramma
nel giro
di qualche giorno
il paese
e in particolare
Roma
sono travolti
dalle manifestazioni
di piazza
e le manifestazioni
sono tutte
per la guerra
perché le manifestazioni
il ministero
le lascia fare
e quelle neutraliste
invece
la polizia picchia
e le disperde
perciò le piazze
sono piene
di gente
che manifesta
per la guerra
chi manifesta
i borghesi
gli impiegati
a Roma
tutti i impiegati
di tutti i ministeri
sono in piazza
a manifestare
gli studenti
che ci credono
e sono convinti
le manifestazioni
impazzano
con una violenza
impressionante
uno dei protagonisti
non è vero
che avevo finito
ce n'è ancora uno
ma lo conoscete tutti
Gabriele D'Annunzio
il più famoso
scrittore letterato
del paese
da anni
in esilio volontario
in Francia
per non pagare i debiti
torna
trionfalmente
in Italia
il 5 maggio
a quarto dei mille
tiene una grandiosa
manifestazione
per l'intervento
in guerra
poi
si ferma
qualche giorno
a Genova
parte
lasciando
risulta
da discussioni
parlamentari
dell'epoca
un astronomico
conto
d'albergo
per lui
e due
signore amiche sue
che lascia
da pagare
al comune
di Genova
va a Roma
e a Roma
appena arrivato
arringa la folla
e questi discorsi
sono di una
violenza
impressionante
chiudiamo
poi ci sarà poco
pochissimo dopo
con brevi brani
dal grande discorso
di D'Annunzio
a Roma
contro Giolitti
compagni
non è più tempo
di parlare
ma di fare
non è più tempo
di concioni
ma di azioni
e di azioni
romane
se è considerato
un crimine
incitare alla violenza
i cittadini
io mi vanterò
di questo crimine
nella Roma
vostra
si tenta
di strangolare
la patria
i neutralisti
con un capestro
prussiano
maneggiato
da quel vecchio
boia
labrone
Giolitti
aveva il labbro
inferiore
sporgente
in tutte le caricature
e lui
che D'Annunzio
chiama in pubblico
nella capitale
quel vecchio
boia
labrone
le cui calcagna
di fuggiasco
sanno la via
di Berlino
se vince lui
ci sarà da vergognarsi
di essere italiani
chiamarsi italiano
sarà nome da nascondere
nome da averne
bruciate le labbra
questo vuol fare
di noi
quel
lansimante
leccatore
di sudici
piedi
prussiani
dopodiché
D'Annunzio
con cui dicendo
però non abbiate paura
perché
c'è il sistema
per fermarli
questa banda
di schiavi
di servi
del nemico
codesto
servidorame
di bassa mano
teme i colpi
a paura
delle busse
a spavento
del castigo
corporale
io ve li raccomando
vorrei poter dire
io ve li consegno
i più maneschi
di voi
saranno
della città
e della salute
pubblica
benemeritissimi
risultato
si moltiplicano
le aggressioni
i pestaggi
di deputati
giolittiani
la casa di giolitti
in via Cavour
viene aggredita
gli studenti
manifestano davanti
a Montecitorio
a un certo punto
invadono
Montecitorio
in queste condizioni
il governo
è dimissionario
il re cerca qualcuno
che prenda
l'incarico
lo chiede a giolitti
giolitti
sbagliando
forse
chi lo sa
dice di no
nessun altro
lo vuol fare
il 16 maggio
il re
ridà l'incarico
a Salandra
e lo rispedisce
alla Camera
e la Camera
che il 10 maggio
aveva una maggioranza
per la pace
il 20 maggio
vota
i poteri
concessi al governo
per la guerra
cosa sia successo
a ogni singolo deputato
che ha cambiato idea
sarebbe bello
andare a vedere tutti
cosa gli è successo
in quei giorni
fatto sta
che la Camera
ha cambiato idea
e il paese
entra in guerra
come combatteremo
questa guerra
e come la vinceremo
lo racconteremo domani
io qui però
volevo chiudere
con una specie
di nemesi
il patto di Londra
firmato il 26 aprile
aveva come clausola
il dover essere
mantenuto segreto
ma nel 1917
c'è la rivoluzione
in Russia
nell'ottobre
del 17 novembre
per noi
i bolcevichi
prendono il potere
e andando a frugare
nei cassetti
dei ministeri
trovano il patto
di Londra
e lo pubblicano
immediatamente
per far vedere
al mondo
che cos'è
la diplomazia
dei paesi
capitalisti
quali sono
gli ideali
per cui
fanno la guerra
vogliamo il Brennero
Bellistria
la Dalmazia
la Turchia
l'Albania
ecco
questa roba
viene pubblicata
in tutto il mondo
da Lenin
peccato
che a quel punto
i nostri veri alleati
non sono più
la Russia
che è crollata
o l'Inghilterra
e la Francia
è entrato in scena
un altro protagonista
e sono gli Stati Uniti
gli Stati Uniti
del presidente Wilson
stanno vincendo
la guerra
e la vinceranno
senza di loro
non sarebbe stata vinta
così facilmente
gli Stati Uniti
sono i padroni del mondo
dal punto di vista economico
hanno in mano
tutti i rubinetti
il grano
il petrolio
e il presidente
degli Stati Uniti
Wilson
è deciso
a finire questa guerra
senza dare soddisfazione
a tutti quegli avidi
arraffatori
che pretendevano
di avere
questo e quello
il presidente Wilson
ha detto chiaramente
al mondo
poi non riuscirà
veramente
nell'intento
ma in quel momento
la sua linea è
libertà per i popoli
autodeterminazione
niente conquiste
niente arraffa
quando gli fanno
vedere il patto
di Londra
il presidente Wilson
fa notare
che gli Stati Uniti
non hanno firmato
niente
loro all'epoca
non c'erano
e perciò
non sono minimamente
tenuti a dare
all'Italia
tutte quelle belle cose
che gli altri
avevano promesso
risultato
alla conferenza
di pace
ci faranno
trangugiare
bocconi amari
e ogni singola cosa
di quelle promesse
che riusciamo ad avere
sarà calata
dall'alto
e non si riuscirà
ad avere tutto
e il paese
che ha già
le ossa rotte
per la guerra
comincerà a sentire
d'annunzio
che parla di
vittoria mutilata
e insomma
succederanno
tante cose
che sapete
questo è
come dire
il frutto ultimo
di quella
diplomazia segreta
che aveva fatto
il patto di Londra
ma appunto
come si arriverà
a questo esito
lo racconteremo domani
grazie